[Music]
hello my name is Julian Polanco I'm a
national master from the state of
Missouri and today we're gonna do
another episode of chess openings
explained tonight's subject will be the
four and nights roy lopez or four night
spanish which starts after E 4 E 5 night
of 396 Knight c3 Knight f6 or Bishop e5
or various other move orders to lead to
this position now the first thing that
we have to recognize the differences
between the four Knights royal apes' and
the regular royal lopez and one major
difference is that white can no longer
play c 3 and d 4 so he's either going to
have to settle on something inferior
like d4 immediately or go for some other
plan
now I'll start in order of like the
least common moves and work we'll work
our way towards the most critical lines
and then we'll look at some games so to
begin with I'll ask our live studio
audience what do you what would you do
here with the black pieces alright so
black in this position wants to develop
his pieces control center and castle
like he does in all major openings the
question here is how do you want to do
that so do you want to develop your
Bishop on f8 do you want to play d6 do
you want to do you want to put your
Bishop on c5 before or 56 any any of
these squares how do you want to develop
and why the why is the most interesting
part let's say I were to play
so the difference between okay let's
start with the regular Ray Lopez so if I
were to play Bishop b5 here and then a6
if I play Bishop c6 DC 695 what would
black play Queen d4 right so Queen d4 is
a double attack on the knight in the
pawn on e4 and black is slightly better
due to his bishop pair and better
development so why would have to go back
you would take on e4 and this position
in practice has been shown to be good
for black so um so black can't sorry why
can't just take the pawn on e5 after a
six but let's let's look at the position
after Knight of three Knight c3 a6 so
what could the potential differences
here be so why is a six maybe less
playable now than it was in the previous
position yes
right so these two pieces are have been
inserted into the position right so the
night was on b1 and the night for on f6
was on GA which means that at the very
least this night will be guarding the
pawn on e4 against the Queen
so in our variation Bishop c6 DC 9895
Queen d4 now would be a huge mistake
because the knight can just come back to
f3 and since the pawn is guarded by the
knight white can just castle next one so
why would be just much better clearly
better if not like winning right so in
this position a six is not not as good
because yeah Knight 95 Queen d4 is less
playable but there is a move here that
black can play so if you are black in
this position what would you maybe try
to play using the same themes as in the
exchange royal up has 94 and if I play
94 then Queen d4 right and so this is
this is the same tactic right I'm
attacking two knights and you can't
defend both of them the problem here is
that white is clearly better after just
castling in the world Ward's of tal you
know at all would sacrifice like a lot
of his pieces right you'd like leave all
of his pieces hanging you can only take
one of them at a time so even though
both of my Knights are hanging you can
only take one of them and whichever one
you choose the one on you five is better
because if you take this one I play rook
e1 and you're your queen and you're keen
on the same file that always leads to
problems especially because you're
losing the rook immediately so Queen e5
is better if d f-- so here d4 and can
anybody tell me why Queen 64 is not
playable
spencer feingold let's go
queenie to is unfortunately refuted by
queenie - but close almost got it
yes ricky one yeah yeah rook when when
the queen and the king are in the same
file this is a common theme a common
tactic that occurs this is this just
went some material for white so black
and basically resign here so that makes
Queenie four unplayable and black would
have to play Queen a5 and this position
is is better for wipe because of his
development advantage so that's why a
six is maybe less desirable in this
specific position as opposed to the
actual royal up house because the
insertion of these moves makes it so
that you have to take on you for with
your knight and then give up a few
tempos in the opening so a6 is a little
bit dubious here some other moose um
okay you would think the Bishop c5 might
be a good move because you're bringing
your bishop to the most active diagonal
right
first of all let's let's talk about this
position so why puts this Bishop on b5
right
why is Bishop c4 maybe not the best move
yes Bishop c4 this is a known thing yes
yes
uh-huh
and defy yes that's correct the reason
why this position is slightly better for
black is you have a pawn in the center
this position is forced because if you
take on d5 you give away the bishop pair
for free so when you reach a position
like this what black is already
established upon in the center of the
board the bishop on e4 isn't very well
placed and blacks already ready to
castle and burn his bishop out well
white can castle next move however his
bishop and he it's you know you still
have to play d3 I mean it's not trapped
but you you still have to play d3 or
something and get it out so black has
some like small development lead and
more control over the center squares so
knowing that this idea exists right and
it's important to point out that in this
position after 94 Bishop f7 isn't very
good for white because after I take and
take once again black has the bishop
pair Bishop e7 I believe this the best
move here although there's nothing wrong
with d5 in King GA this position is also
just good for black two bishops in the
center the fact that you I mean you've
kind of Castle it anyway
right so you saw the problem with your
work on h8 and you're just better and I
think Bishop e7 is more precise anyway
just stopping that and you get to play
d5 so knowing that that exists what
could be the potential problem with
Bishop c5 in this position yeah
so if Knight takes pawn now then 99
it's important to note once again that
if black does this kind of thing King up
to 94 white is just clearly about her
after t4 I mean to bishops for free so
but 95 d4 56 f4 so if you were to take
right now Bishop e5 castles castles and
Bishop d3 this position is just equal
but white can play d4 here
sorry f4 with the point that now if I
take back I'm once again for working
your pieces you move your night away and
then I play another fork what this line
no we'll go over that line later yeah
well we'll go over the fake Halloween
gambit recommended by Mario Roper in a
second Bishop before takes takes a three
and this position after Bishop a5 is
also approximately equal yes in this
position I don't know is it was this too
fast night and the night has to go back
to c6 I mean the night is the best place
on c6 because it's controlling d4 after
a 5 this is another fork right so black
has to respond to this you want to keep
your Bishop you don't over your night
because if I take your Bishop right I
get to bishops which is an advantage and
also this structure isn't good for black
any questions so far
everything good Queeny so right okay so
Queenie seven here
the problem is that I just Castle right
and I assume you want to play this trick
but it doesn't work because I take this
guy and it Queen takes I have two
bishops and once again I'm gonna I think
it's there's there's too many too many
problems you have to solve here so this
position is just good for white
yeah 94 the point is okay everybody in
the class sees why this is a bad move
right yes all right
somebody somebody in the back do you
what what's the refutation of Queen d4
I'll give you him these pieces are lined
up correct and the Queen cannot move
because it's pinned to the king so white
loses his Queen which is why I have to I
mean I can probably take either one of
these pieces honestly both should lead
to an advantage but I think I think the
take in d6 should just be one II and I
can check the computer okay point six
isn't much okay actually funny this is
just way because I have ninety four and
then I take on d6 anyway so yeah this is
plus five
this position is obviously bad if if you
don't do something immediate because if
white if White's allowed to complete
development before black is then he'll
have two advantages the bishop pair and
an time so here black should move his
bishop away to be for ef6 Queen f6 a3
because if you if you were to just
castle here then your d4 pawn is hanging
so you want to you want to kick the
bishop away and this position is very
unclear but computer shows approximate
equality so that's why maybe taking on
e5 immediately isn't correct but it is
an idea so here white should just Castle
and then if black castles now it's a
different story
95 is very strong well not okay it's the
best move in the position I'm going but
first let's talk about d6 so after
Bishop c5 castles black doesn't have to
play castles right
he can play d6 with the idea of stopping
our thread of 95 because if you were to
play 95 now I would just recapture with
my pawn so what could the potential
problem of d6 be yeah the the initial
disadvantage is that blacks Knight spend
and actually that's very important it's
very important that this move right now
here today this minute the knight is
pinned because there's something you can
do
so if black weren't is so if you were to
place some past mode like a3 and black
castles black is fine in fact I would
prefer black because the Bishop on c5 is
probably other better than the Bishop of
b5 the reason why black is not better
here is white has a concrete trick so
after d6 white complete d4 now you would
think I have one two three attackers on
the d4 square and I have one two
defenders but that isn't actually true
because the knight on c6 isn't actually
defending the d4 pawn so ii takes d4
Knight takes d4 Bishop d7 night of five
is as a possibility but this type of
structure and generally is slightly
better for white because you have a tiny
bit more space now the question is does
blacks activity compensate him for
having this like slight disadvantage in
space here white translates that into
being able to play Knight of five if my
pawn war on e3 I wouldn't be a little
plain out of five that bishop would just
take my knight so castles Bishop g5
Bishop takes f5 e takes f5 and White has
a slight advantage due to his bishop
pair although his structure has become
weakened because he has doubled pawns
and the opponent of five isn't very
strong yeah
the line play could continue 90 for
Bishop d3 d5 Bishop f6 Queen f6 95 Queen
g5 97 rook 88 this is all computer
nonsense can look this up at home or
anywhere else if if you care to so but
the point is here white is slightly
better yes but anyway continue on moving
rapidly on see ya so Bishop c5 is
slightly inferior of a move to the move
let's say a ship t6 even so Bishop d6 is
kind of a weird move right it's
interesting so what is a disadvantage of
playing Bishop d6 can anybody tell me
the obvious thing yes it blocks the pawn
which blocks in my bishop which means
that my the bishop on c8 won't be moving
for a while but the thing is it's really
hard for white to take advantage of this
and in the normal royal apes' the way
you would take advantage of somebody
playing Bishop d6 is by establishing a
pawn on d4 unfortunately here that's not
exactly pasta
because black has a new five point and
the fact that a knight on c3 is really
important so white would place C 3 and d
4 and the bishop on d6 would look really
silly now in this position if you were
to play d4 black could just take it and
there's there's not really a threat of a
V 5 yet so like Knight takes Knight
takes takes like a castle and once again
a five would fail to the same trick that
we mentioned before so that's not really
an issue here
so black black has to solve his problems
but you can't immediately take advantage
of the bishop b96
the best move here is d3 a6 Bishop a4
Bishop c4 also the ship's e4 is also
playable Bishop a4 is slightly better
because after Bishop I'm sorry Bishop a4
slightly better pick scepter but ship c4
the black and just play Knight a5 and
chase chase this guy down immediately
so Bishop a a 4h 6h 6 is played to
prevent Bishop g5 but Kathleen
immediately immediately is also fine
Bishop g5 is well met by b5 and Bishop
e7 this position is also approximately
equal although I would prefer to be
white yeah
Knight a5 in this position after so if I
were after castles Bishop g5 if you were
to chase after my Bishop here white
would be slightly better after 95 Bishop
e7 takes takes and I have I have
slightly better pieces than you the
bishop on c8 still needs to be developed
and by the way this structure that's
going to occur because I'm losing the
bishop pair is actually even though the
pawns are doubled they're they're
stronger than their colleagues like
castles takes takes so the pawn is
improved from a2 to be 3 because it's
going towards the center
and puns that are on the B file I love
this thing that you assert old me when I
was very low rated I mean pawns that are
on the B file right they they can move
in three directions pawns on the a file
can only move in two directions it's
like so obvious when you think about it
but the reason why these pawns might be
bad is because the the pawn on b2 can't
move
but overall the you get you get the file
and if you if you can make the pawn on
beef before b3 useful and fix your
opponent structure then it could be an
advantage
anyway white is slightly better here
black shouldn't black shirt and chase
out for the bishop in this position he
should instead just play b5 and sorry
after ever shipped you five he should
play b5 Bishop b3 in Bishop e7 breaking
the pin so let's move on to h6 a3 so a3
is obviously played to prevent b5 and
Knight a5 winning the bishop on b3 so b5
anyway
there should be three Bishop e7 and I
would say this position is maybe very
slightly better for for white just
because black pieces are a little funny
like they're not the best place the
bishop on b7 is striking against this
wall on d3 84 and the bishop on d6 is
stereo 95 but black has black has ideas
of 94 castling and he has no real
weaknesses as far as structure is
concerned so this is also a line that's
very playable for black and if you would
prefer to play Bishop d6 over Bishop c5
I would not blame you so Bishop c5 is
was are like inferior move to Bishop d6
so let's move on to the one of the main
lines actually which is Bishop before
now this was the old main line and the
one that I was actually taught
the line would go like this castles
castles d3d six Bishop g5 and here so so
far both sides have played symmetrically
right the the whole board is symmetrical
but the problem for black is that if he
continues playing in this style then he
could very well like losing the next two
moves because Bishop Bishop g4 would
lose immediately 295 because I'm
attacking the F the f6 Knight right with
these two so you're going to get double
pawns but if you continue in the same
way and you're getting double pawns
my my one tempo matters because I'm
attacking b4 + f6 and this comes with
check so here think the way this goes is
see
actually let's see yeah I'm sorry Bishop
f6 and if Queen f6 the 95 ones
immediately because before is hanging
right here now if you were to play G
takes here then the then the structural
defect is noticeable you can't keep this
pin because of G for this type of
position is is very good for white
because the bishop on g6 has no squares
and so you can't really play
symmetrically you have to do something
else and what I was told is that black
is completely fine in this position
after Bishop c3 BC three Queen e7 rook
e1 defending or actually I was told that
c4 was the move here which is incorrect
but okay I was told that c4 should be
played Knight d8 c3 trying to bring the
bishop back 96 and black is fine because
I've kicked the bishop away from the the
h4 to d8 diagonal because Bishop h4
leaves the f4 square tender so probably
like Bishop e3 is best and black has no
bad pieces and that's true for this
position this position is fine is fine
for black like this is this position is
like equal it's fine right but
any okay so but instead they they
realize that this position here after a
rookie 1.d4 oh sorry
rookie 198 which is the maneuver that
everybody's taught put your night on you
six it controls they a Foursquare White
has this move d4 which was the point of
rookie one rookie one defense the e the
e4 pawn and after 96 boy it has a very
nice move Bishop c1 c5 and Bishop f1 and
remain slightly better out of the
opening which is weird because this
opening doesn't really have a good
reputation for keeping the the advantage
the White House so I mean this position
is slightly better for white we'll
discuss that later but let's look at
alternatives so black doesn't have to
play this way black black can play
Bishop b4 d3 I'm sorry castles and after
d3 he can play Bishop instead of Bishop
c3 he can just play d6 then white plays
Bishop g5 and here instead of Bishop c3
black could just play 97 and this is
very good equalizing chances but
unfortunately I think I found an
advantage for a white after Bishop f6 g
f6 Knight I was right
d4 c6 Bishop d3 9g 692 k98 c3 and the
problem is black has a bad structure and
he's not lost by any means and he has
the two bishops to compensate for a
structural defect but I think that in
this specific position the struck the
inability to play f5 will matter at some
point so white white white has the
better chances here because he controls
more squares any questions about
anything that I just said
King h8 oh yeah so in this position the
reason why the King goes to h8 is you
have the open G file right and the only
way that your rook makes any sense is if
it goes there so you put your rook on G
a and then your rook makes a lot of
sense in chess you want your pieces to
see right like imagine at the start of
the game you know they're like blind
children you want to help them see so
you put them on you know you give them
all the opportunities to see everything
and the rook on g8 I mean it just sees
everything so that's why you put your
keen on Ajay unfortunately I think the
fact that it white has controlled the
center here I mean like black isn't lost
he's only like slightly worse but I
think the central control and hit the
better structure gives him the better
game so so but I mean to be fair black
has two bishops he has the G file and
also like good good chances for counter
play so that is that is an alternative
for black oh hold on I forgot to mention
Mario's line let's go let's go even
further back in this position black can
play g6 but here there's a the pseudo
Halloween gambit which is 95 95 d4 I'm
only mentioning this because Halloween
is like coming up yeah okay but this
position is slow I mean better for black
because you're down a piece unclear you
can look it up not interesting bishop
before
castles castles d-36 instead of instead
of playing like that is very possible at
any moment black could play Bishop c3 BC
3 and instead of playing Queen e7 he
could just play 97 and here white would
be slightly better after Knight h4 c6
and Bishop a4 I keep the bishop pair and
I'm preventing the knight from coming to
g6 because I'll play Knight f5
so I'm negating or rather I'm
controlling I'm controlling the f5
square more so this position is very
slightly better for white Bishop d7
could be one a six should pay for Bishop
c6 is all obviously nothing because you
give your Bishop away for nothing
so this is equal b5 should be three I
mean I have to save my Bishop right h6
Bishop age who are in this position is
also very slightly better for white
because I have two bishops although that
is a certainly a very solid alternative
for black and if any black player wants
to play it then that's that's also
totally fine it doesn't lose by force so
let's let's move on to the main
variation which is here actually sorry
this is this is like the starting
position we'll look at some games here
white is slightly better but now we'll
reach the real main lines which start
after the very interesting Knight d4 so
you look at this moving you're like well
I mean Weiss play has been so timid
right
he brings his night so I mean I was
right he controlled the center he
brought both his knights out then he put
his Bishop on b5 the black can actually
afford to just play Knight d4 because 95
is not it's not very good because
yeah you can put a media pressure on the
night and take on you for and I mean
blacks gonna have the bishop Heron is
already like slightly better so you can
see here so yeah you can't take the pawn
on e5 immediately so the question is
where do you move your bishop both both
obvious moves are very interesting which
I would choose Bishop a4 and Bishop c4
the other moves aren't so interesting so
if you go back to e2 then black is
obviously just fine after taking on e2
and playing d6 bishop pair the best
Philidor that's ever occurred ever
castles isn't very good because you take
on d5 and then you play C 6 and d6 d4
Queen c7 once again this is the greatest
Philidor opening ever black is for
choice even I mean that's subjective I
guess it's equal but I would rather be
blind yeah
so let's move on to the two critical
continuations we'll talk about Bishop c4
first because less critical
now black sorry what could it be
sorry no that's right black could be
very solid here and just play Knight f3
I believe I think this is fine yeah just
takes and then Bishop c5 and this
position is completely equal this is
very solid
but if black wants to play like in a
more interesting manner with Bishop c5
just leaving the pawn sit on e5 but
continue to continuing to develop then
you you get some very interesting
positions because in 95 black is forced
to play Queen e7 cashless doesn't make
any sense because then you just lost a
pawn for nothing you need to attack the
knight on e5 if the knight goes away
then you play d5 striking at the center
the pawn can't take because of the rules
of chess
so Bishop takes which could be a
potential advantage of putting your
bishop on c4
although d5 wouldn't be possible if the
bishop lying for
Bishop g4 and yeah here black is black
is uh gonna make gonna make sure that
white as structural damage done to his
position these pawns will be weak and
it's I mean White has a sleeping Queen
site everybody over there is blind and
castling kingside isn't very appealing
because of all blacks pieces are going
to be coming in sorry so here here you
have to play d3 in order to maybe get
your king to the Queen side castles
Queen side is is the best move Bishop e3
here its playable Knight d5 and this
line that that was put in the database
many times by very strong players
actually like there's not monthly of
against Rishabh off and karyakin and ye
against Adams these are all like top 10
top 15 players in the world they've all
played this line and the results like
would indicate out of 16 games that the
position is good for black but my
analysis shows something different and I
mean the computers here you can you can
see for yourself riff d5 Edie Bishop
sorry rook e8 Bishop f3 care GF this is
also just good for white because you
keep you keep your pawn and you get to
Castle probably so yeah
but I'm sorry you don't keep your pawn
you're just up the exchange for some
mild compensation anyway the main line
in the database here was rook e8
since the strong players played it
that's what we that's what we look at
but it seems to me that white is just
better after castles which is really
hard to play but night of 3gf Bishop h3
and after rook e1 Bishop e3 F force
sorry so this position Bishop if F at e3
F force just winning if Queen h4 white
is slightly well white is better after
KH one so anyway the games the games
usually continued c3 and this position
is approximately equal after night of
three GF because they found some
perpetual maybe it's some force draw
line
so castle this is interesting but
probably probably best here is just
after d3 to play c6
and yeah if Bishop b3 then then you can
put more pressure on e5 and this is I
mean white might have some slight
advantage but like should be fine
instead of this of course black
objectively should probably play Knight
f3 and Bishop c5 the solid approach but
that was that was the interesting line
so let's continue with Bishop a4 which
is more critical now we get into a whole
bunch of crazy variations because all
the variations are mixed together the
best the most common move is Bishop a4
Bishop c5 a lot of games that I was
looking at when Bishop a4 c6 let's talk
about that first the point that after 95
you have both d6 here and D 5 D 5 is
supposedly less critical but it has
higher level games so let's look at D 6
first so Knight f3 Bishop g4 d3 d5 IDI
Knight 95 does anybody have any
questions about any moves that were
played there's all this like very clear
all right moving on edie night d have to
recapture your pawn castles 93 BC night
of three GF Bishop e6 Black has a lot of
compensation for the pony has sacrificed
obviously because white has structural
defects on the Queen side but I mean the
ivory and the very obvious ones on the
King side so so black stands fine here
after Bishop e3 over 56 F for Queen f6
Bishop e6 FV Queen h5 I mean the line
this is this is all computer analysis
but this is approximately equal so d6 d6
is very playable and very interesting
but a lot of top players are trying to
play d5 here where you get a very
imbalanced position after d3 Bishop d6
attacking the 95 if the knight moves to
f3 then Bishop g4 is very strong like in
every other position but why does f4 so
now the bishop doesn't really have a
purpose it's not going to take on any 5
anymore
it moves to c5 preventing white from
castling because there would be some
nasty discoveries so in this position II
d5 castles ignoring the pawn on d5
because you can't capture with the pawn
and you really want to capture with the
pawn taking away that night just wastes
time so castles dc-6b c6h 3 and in this
position white White has a very hard
time castling kingside
and his development is very Oh oops his
development is very poor so he has to
try to try to get his King to safety on
the Queen side we'll take a look at some
high-level games here later
so this is this is also very interesting
most people as I said before play Bishop
c5 here the point that after 95 you have
Queenie sorry
castles Queenie 7 here is not very good
because of 93 and b5 is the best move
here 94 castles is better for white
because I'm once again tactics due to
the Queen and the king being on the same
file or very visible here and the white
slight lead in development should give
them an advantage anyway so castles is
best 93 Bishop b6 is the only good move
because you need to keep your Bishop on
this side of the board aimed at the King
just a future hiding spot so e 5
attacking the knight and that goes back
to EA
95 I white really wants to get rid of
the bishop on b6 which could potentially
be a monster d6 93 the knight transfers
to this square because you need to you
need to be able to retrieve your Bishop
from a4 and have your pieces be a little
bit more harmonious and anyway c5 is
played to reinforce the knight and
potentially give more squares to the
other pieces and place it for later c3
Knight a5 Queen h5 is my recommended
novelty Bishop c2 is also played here
this position is very unclear and
there's lots of variations to be
discussed I highly recommend doing more
analysis on this specific position here
because I mean it's a lot of fun just to
look at the variations
I would I would start with Queen h5
because I I mean there's this line Queen
h4 of 93 93 and night before coming to
d5 and it would seem to me the white as
a slight advantage but I'm not going to
claim that to be true or false yet and
not enough analysis has been
so if any theoreticians want to look at
this position they can I mean there's no
reason to I guess but for fun
this is this is an interesting line to
go over anyway let's look at some games
so remember our original tabia from the
bishop before line so Bishop b4 so black
is Anatoly Karpov which everybody in
this room should should have at least
heard of it was a world champion and one
of the strongest chess players in
history so he's playing the black pieces
against Peter Svidler who is also a very
strong chess player one of the strongest
players in Russia right now and probably
top 15 he's definitely in the top 20
he's always he's always there always
above like 2750 anyway so d3 bishops III
bc 3 so Karpov is playing like everybody
was taught he was everybody's taught to
take the knight on c3 play queen e7 and
then put their knight on da they're this
is like the classic maneuver but
unfortunately for him I mean it's not
it's not good against every setup the
White has and I don't think it's very
good here because D 496 Bishop c1 c5
Bishop f1 and it actually surprises me
quite a bit that this position has been
seen so much in Grandmaster practice
because it's so easy to understand the
plans for white white can play on both
sides of the board he has two bishops
and all of his pieces makes sense like I
the pawns on c3 and d4 right they
reinforce they reinforce each other the
doubled pawns is maybe like a slight
concession I have the choice of playing
d5 whenever I want
I have central space and I can I can
play on the Kings side with maybe g3
Knight h4 and f4 and maybe get some kind
of attack going anyway the game
continued rook da
g3 as I said so white wants to play
actually it's not clear where white
wants to play it but the bishop could be
improved
um actually g2 isn't a very good square
but white wants to move his pawns toward
his towards his opponents King and boy
can play on both side of the board and I
mean black is just kind of sitting back
and waiting to see what happens
rook ba was played brick ba was played
to gain some space with b5 why prevents
that with a four-night f8 put in a dish
additional protection on e5 I mean
there's not a lot to recommend for black
like there's no active moves that you
can really come up with that are any
good so white black Hester is a resort
to shuffling his PC pieces around while
white actually comes up with like real
plants so Knight h4 potentially aiming
at f5 but really the knight is riemann
to Vereen itself to g2 and possibly e3
where later it'll become more useful so
Bishop g4 f3 this was in White's plan
anyway he's gonna push his pawns on the
Kings side Bishop d7 92 queenie 8 which
is a very dubious move why is Queen e8 a
bad or dubious move can anybody find the
best move for white what did Queen e8 do
what was what was the Queen on e7 do
doing that the Queen on e8 is no longer
doing something that that you mentioned
in the opening
yes that is correct and the reason why
that's important is after Bishop g5
black cannot afford to have his his
structure damage like this so he has to
burn his Queen back to protect his
knight so you've gained an extra tempo
by putting your Bishop on g5 you've
attacked the night this is this is a
horrible structure to have because your
opponent might just checkmate you so
Bishop g5 Queenie 693 it's all right did
you raise your hand er my ass bad ice
bad everything anyway h6 Bishop c4 and
here white is completely winning because
if you go back to defend your knight by
the way it was better for black just to
admit that he played a mistake it's
really hard psychologically to do this
but when you when your opponent plays I
move like Bishop g5 to just go back to
e7 but it's really like the best thing
to do in the position he didn't have
anything better than this Queen e6 was
just kind of saying oh yeah I saw Bishop
g5 this was my idea anyway but yeah
Queeny Queeny 6 is unfortunate because
now after 93 h6 is is wrong as Bishop c4
attacks the Queen and the Queen were to
go back to f7 sree 7 then when 95 comes
not only do I damage your structure but
I'm winning loads of material if you
take back then this is a fork winning a
queen and if you go to e6 then this is a
discovery winning your Queen so so the
Queen has to play sorry the Queen has to
go to h3
but unfortunately the end is near Bishop
f6 GF f4 cd4 was put in the game it
doesn't it doesn't matter
everything everything loses can somebody
tell me how many squares the Queen has
you can use pen and paper at home how
many squares can the Queen move to
without getting taken
this could be a trick question yes that
is correct so if you were to attack the
queen you would win the queen so how do
you attack the queen
eat oh sorry yes bye
no no you can can't go so [ __ ]
yeah the bishop can go back to f1 but
unfortunately there's a catch
Queen now has the e6 squared right so
knowing that the Queen can go back after
your Bishop knows right is there
something you can do to prevent the
Queen from going backwards if you put
the bishop on e6 the Queen will go to e6
right
yeah the pawn unfortunately I think oh
and so the problem with that is you're
giving the Queen another square right so
so you're you're giving the Queen the h4
square but you have the right idea roll
in execution yes
a ch3 the problem here is is is that
yeah the black bishop will be able to
protect the Queen but the queen is more
valuable than the P well the theoretical
but so the hypothetical bishop that's
arriving on f1 so when when the bishop
does arrive on f1 it doesn't matter if
your bishop protects it because
obviously a queen is worth more than the
bishop
but yeah so the question is how can i
play bishop f1 right without letting the
Queen come back to the game that is
correct
f5 and the game is basically is
basically over because I mean the rest
of the game continued takes bishop went
back to f1 the Queen is trapped right I
mean has no squares if you go to g4 I
take go to h5 I take it's the worst Aero
ever I take go to h4 I take here I take
go to g2 I take every square is covered
so all I have to do is take the Queen
right so yeah the game continued here
Bishop f5 Bishop h3 takes now how do you
be as precise as possible what would you
play with white yes anyway you had it
you had a thought
Queen h5 is correct because it attacks
the bishop and the pawn on h6 yes so
Bishop e6 Queen h6 d 5 now the rook
takes on e3 because I mean it's better
not to allow counter play if you like
black's pawn and III could potentially
be very strong right if I play d4 and
it's reinforced the structure
potentially could be shown it's all
nonsense like white is it winning in
every variation you could play almost
any move here like any reasonable move
and you would win but you want to finish
the game as cleanly as possible because
your opponent is you know an X I mean a
current or ex rel champion I don't know
what year what year this game was played
to 2003 okay so he extra champion right
so x world champion a champion Anatoly
Karpov one of the strongest players in
chess history maybe if you make some
inaccuracies he'll get out
so Peters Fidler very very strong
obviously didn't let that happen
rookie 3d for Queen f6 so you want to
take away as many defenders away from
you want to take the defenders away from
the king with Queen f6 it's easier to
checkmate 97 Queen goes back to h6 took
the pawn goes back to its ideal Square
rook c8 rookie for rooks III rookie 5
and after Rick c6 Rick g5 black resigned
unfortunately I think that's all I have
time for thank you very much
it's Julian Polanco my coverage of the
four night Spanish
[Music]